it is one conflict after another Lisa
Bracken's home in silk Colorado sits
between to fracking paths she's waged
about a dozen legal battles with the
driller in Kanna but says the biggest
was over a 2,000 for natural gas seep
into nearby divide Creek and canna
denies wrongdoing in 2004 you could
light a flame a foot high off that Creek
Bracken says Encana offered her a
nondisclosure agreement as part of a
settlement but that she turned it down
she called it a common practice in
exchange for a couple of bucks here we
get your silence here for a lot of
landowners you know they they kind of
sadly they welcome that because it is
such a contentious environment it's not
just silt bloomberg reviewed hundreds of
regulatory and legal filings and found
drillers paying for silence over water
contamination complaints and at least
half a dozen states at the same time the
industry contends there's nothing to
hide has never been a case of
groundwater contamination as a result of
hydraulic fracturing that's something
the EPA is studying the agency also
warned in a 1987 report that secret
settlements could make it harder to
collect data on fracking's water and
health impacts it's the equivalent of
burying the bodies they just don't want
this information to ever come and haunt
them again a young woman take Laura
Amos's story shown in the documentary
the split estate though the state found
no evidence that fluids linked to cancer
entered her well Emo's blamed fracking
when she developed an adrenal tumor and
canna disagreed with a Moses claims but
the company still bought her property
here in silk for three hundred and ten
thousand dollars as part of the
settlement Amos agreed to a
non-disclosure packed the outspoken
advocate who was described by The Denver
Post as the Erin Brockovich of Garfield
County has since moved more than 60
miles away she refused Bloomberg's
interview requests and when state
regulators subpoenaed her to testify
this winner she backed out the only gas
industry essentially said if you speak
we will see you Megan Hughes Bloomberg
silk Colorado
you